good morning
and welcome to the star's 25th
anniversary celebration
my name is sandy chang associate dean of
stem education at yale college
and director of the stars program i will
be moderating today's sessions
we gather to celebrate stars for the
first time since this inception
by any measure stars has been
extraordinarily successful
women and underrepresented students
participated in stars
are significantly more likely to persist
in stem majors and to pursue
stem disciplines after graduation we
will hear from some of these
extraordinary stars alums today
students who will also get to meet them
in zoom breakout sessions later on
we'll also hear from some of the leaders
who made the stars program
possible many of these individuals
continue to serve this
program today a testament to their
dedication to make your stem more
inclusive and equitable
president peter salovey the chris
argaris professor of psychology will
lead off the program with a short video
hello i'm peter salovey president of
yale university
thank you for inviting me to join you to
celebrate the 25th anniversary of stars
a quarter century ago professor kurt
zilm
and university secretary and vice
president for university life
kim goff cruz recognized the need for a
program like this
thanks to their vision hundreds of yale
students have gained
first-hand research experience and
support
for navigating their majors and building
careers
women and others from underrepresented
groups
in science have received the mentorship
and opportunities we
know are essential for success in stem
fields i also want to express my
appreciation to dean sandy chang for
leading stars with such enthusiasm
and dedication many faculty members have
been critical partners in this work
they've taught courses and served as
role models
research shows that role models play a
powerful role particularly for students
who come from backgrounds that aren't
well represented
in sciences accomplished educators and
researchers at yale
like dean chang dean marvin chun
professor zilm and professor maguiri
have inspired students through this
program
the rewards have been great star's
alumni have gone on to build careers
and make contributions to science
technology and medicine
at yale welcoming students and scholars
from diverse backgrounds
is a university-wide priority we know
diversity is
integral to excellence fueling discovery
and answering our most urgent questions
as you know based on engagement from
every part of our community
i launched programs that are part of the
next phase
of the belonging at yale initiative
these programs
delve into our history assess and
build on our current actions support
members of the university community
and create a stronger yale for the
future
they help us to continue to lead the way
in teaching and research of the highest
caliber as we collaborate on this vital
work
it is especially important to foster a
sense of belonging
and inclusion in stem
we've made progress in increasing
representation from diverse groups
in these fields but there is more to do
we know that our students today are the
leaders
and the mentors of tomorrow
and so programs like stars are essential
to fulfilling yale's mission to improve
the world today
and for future generations
thank you to everyone who has made this
program such a success
and congratulations on this wonderful
milestone
i look forward to the next 25 years of
stars
at yale thank you very much president
salovey
our next speaker is marvin chung ding of
yale college
the richard m colgate professor of
psychology and professor of neuroscience
ding chang good morning everyone
um such an exciting day um uh
to be here for the 25th anniversary of
stars
uh it is absolutely a top priority for
yale college
uh and as a scientist uh leading a brain
imaging lab i'm using i'm showing our
brain scanner behind me
it's a program that's very dear to my
heart
as you just heard stars really
exemplifies
president salovey's mission for yale to
be their research university most
committed
to teaching and learning um and we're
also
you know really grateful to university
secretary and vice president for
student life kim goff cruz uh who not
only
uh you know who leads our diversity
equity inclusion and belonging
initiatives um that that is a major
priority for yale
um i i really uh celebrate her uh for
founding this
uh stars program um along with uh
professor
zim and professor kenneth nelson
uh and and i also you know just wan i'm
grateful for this opportunity to thank
uh and to recognize uh dr sandy chang
professor sandy chang
uh he is truly passionate and tireless
in his leadership of stars uh he
he thinks about stars all the time uh
and
you really cannot ask for a better
colleague a better
associate dean of science and
quantitative reasoning education
uh you know as an accomplished md phd
clinician and scientist
uh himself uh and as a yale alum a yale
college alum
uh he i think he really embodies uh what
we're trying to achieve with this
program
uh even as he um uh says one of his
motivations for
uh leading this program is is is that he
did not get the benefit from something
like this himself
um i i really also want to thank our
our fabulous colleagues and faculty for
teaching in this program and for
mentoring uh students in your labs
uh you you know you're you are the
engine that really make this
possible and make it successful and and
of course i i
applaud the students uh many of you who
are here as alumni
uh again serving as role models uh but
it's really your engagement with the
program
uh you know you're giving your best uh
is
is is what allows us which has kept this
program strong
for 25 years uh you know in this program
you've demonstrated
dedication persistence and resilience
you know science is hard
uh it has a lot of setbacks but but your
ability to overcome these challenges
uh bad data um uh just you know hard to
long days
uh you know it's it's what you've
demonstrated in the labs
um that again uh has has made this
program so successful
and uh and and i'm you know nothing
makes me happier than to see
our students uh get you know um
uh thrive through this program uh and to
uh have good rewards uh after graduation
uh good careers after graduation uh
based on the experiences that you've
gained through stars
uh and so so it's dean i'm grateful for
this opportunity to thank you all
and i want to just close by saying that
it's absolutely
a top goal for me to expand this program
so that every student who wants to
participate
can benefit uh from it uh and so i
really hope even
as soon as the 30th anniversary and and
ideally even sooner
i or my successor uh will be able to say
that this program is fully funded
um uh so but today i look forward to
celebrating this milestone with you all
and i thank you all for being here and
have a good day
thank you so much jing chung and thank
you for your continued support
for your stem our next speaker is kim
goff cruz
the secretary and vice president for
university
life secretary cruz
thank you dr chang um first of all i am
so excited to be here and i'm honored to
be here to celebrate with you
uh this milestone in the star's history
i
as many people mentioned was um there at
the very very beginning
um and um and i'm surprised and grateful
that it has lasted as long as it has i
wasn't sure that it would
um uh professor zilman i were part of a
small
team of uh and uh dr nelson also a small
team of faculty and staff that
were looking to create a program
particularly for students of color and
women
that would ensure that they could
persist
in the sciences and it's interesting
because it succeeded a program
that was called amps it was called the
academic mentoring program in the
sciences
um that probably that wasn't really
working as well so we took a year off to
actually figure out what we wanted to do
and most people don't know this before
stars it was nothing
it was a year of nothing and then we
actually went on a little bit of a tour
and doing some some research
around the country to figure out what we
might do differently
and with that wonderful team of ken
nelson
dr zim iona black came in just at the
right time
and then and kayla's came in a little
later we
began to uh i would say actually the
faculty began to develop a program that
they thought was really worthy of the
students
um that they wanted to provide service
for they had
four but main themes that they were
really focusing on as they were building
the program
one is we were all focused on following
the students particularly that
initial student group what their needs
were and so stars one was the first
iteration
of stars then star summer because the
students were going to go into the
summer program
then stars too because the students were
coming you know becoming sophomores in
junior so we followed the students we
were very focused on
focusing on the whole student and not
just the at their academic
work and we were very focused on having
very high expectations
but also creating community and not
competition
and so you'll see those things i think
have really gone through
stars for the last 25 years with this
wonderful group of faculty and staff who
have
nurtured it over the years as well i am
grateful to those initial students who
um
allowed us to be worked so closely with
them um
and to um kayla centauri and
particularly to dr black
as well who who passed last summer but
he was such a guiding light
as a wonderful mentor for the for the
students over the years um
i know she wherever she is is pleased to
see that this program is thriving
to see the work that her students she
worked with are doing and to see that
all of you have continued to do
um and participate in the program that
is thriving so again
thank you congratulations to all stars
to the
administrators who have followed and
it's the wonderful work that we see
coming out of the program itself
congratulations
thank you very much secretary goff cruz
and thank you for founding stars our
next speaker
is kurt zellm the william k lammon
junior professor of chemistry and chair
of the department of chemistry at yale
professor zell
thank you sandy it's a real pleasure to
be here i
you know i it's hard to believe 25 years
um i would have never never thought
starting with amps and i've got
got to mention one name i haven't heard
is bob wyman
a professor of uh mcdb who
uh i think really was the founder um i
i've been given credit for a lot of
things that bob wyatt started
um uh when this especially when this
became an hhmi program
and then we've ever since uh you know
through
many rounds of funding you know uh uh
when this was
innovative uh you know across the
country
we were we were copied uh you know it
was this most sincere form of flattery
by other universities copying
uh what was done in stars uh but after
about
15 years or so 10 or 15 years funding
agencies started saying well this isn't
innovative anymore
you know this is just something you
should do we don't need to provide seat
funding anymore
and so it's it's been uh my
part my my goal has been to to push the
institution
to find a way to endow this program and
to fully fund it
and it is so uh um
so fulfilling to hear uh first uh
from uh uh it was at the time was dean
holloway and now dean
chun and to hear in the yale science
priorities
uh that this is an institutional
priority and it's not a question of
if but when uh and uh and i hope you're
all
uh able to you know participate and and
help us
you know in this goal of making certain
this program is
is funded and can be expanded for future
generations
of yale students i wish you were all
here
uh that so much has changed
since you were on campus many of you
there has been an enormous amount of
buildings going on i'm
speaking to you with the background from
my renovated office
in sterling chemistry and and i'm very
proud of my labs
that uh are in sterling chemistry but
the spaces that you were probably most
familiar with
you know where maybe you took a class in
in
scl 160 which is about half again bigger
than it
than it was uh with the demonstration
hoods
uh the um the old
the old uh teaching labs that you had
with the wooden sashes have been
replaced by
an amazing new teaching facility where
every student in organic chemistry gets
their own hood
uh uh to use it's just it's just an
amazing brilliant facility that just
you know showcases yale's commitment to
stem there's a new
research building uh that's actually
sterling there's a new research building
for
for for chemistry um and uh
there is now a new uh biology building
that's replaced
gibbs uh which is amazing so it you know
i really wish we were on campus i hope
we have an on campus one
uh so that you all get a chance to see
the
facilities that star students are able
to to work in now
and i'm very excited to hear about
uh in the breakout sessions where which
you've all been up to
uh and uh and to get to catch up and
and and hopefully be able to engage you
to help feature five star students
and uh yale as we try to fully fund this
program
thank you and welcome thank you very
much professor zom
our first stars alumni speaker
is carissa sanchez the faculty of the
facility administrator at the vita
dialysis clinic
clarissa
hi can everyone hear me all right
all right sounds good thank you so much
for having me with you guys this morning
i'm very excited to be here i was a
mechanical engineering major and
graduated from yale in
2015 and then went on to
really just do actual engineering work
so i worked with alcoa we were
doing a lot of aerospace manufacturing
for for jet engine components
and i got a lot of my exposure there i
i came in through the stars summer
program and
maybe like like a lot of other you know
first generation
urm students i honestly had no idea what
i wanted to study
and yeah very much joined stars and
very luckily matched with the shrowers
materials science and mechanical
engineering lab and
um what's really grateful for for the
mentorship especially of kylis who i see
is on today
and yeah i was i was able to find out
that i really enjoyed the research i
also
kind of stereotypically found that there
was a very strong connection with these
materials that we were developing
that could be used for for healthcare
applications
and i ended up staying with with that
same lab i found during my start summer
for all four years of undergrad
and was able to help a phd student
develop these these diabetes blood
glucose sensors out of the materials we
were developing
and that kind of spurred the the rest of
my career honestly because i i had this
light bulb moment where i realized that
um you know i'm from the town of the
nation
and my tribe has the highest rate of
diabetes for any people group
um across across the world so over 50 of
the the tribe has diabetes by the time
they're 25 years old
um and it just stars you know curriculum
and and being able to go through that
just really lit a fire under me to be
able to
have a good career within stem but also
to do something good for my people and
underrepresented communities
um so you know going through my actual
engineering job
it was fun i was learning a lot i also
wanted to do more
um and you know get back to doing
something that would impact
my people so i went to business school
a little off the the beaten path for a
typical you know stem engineering
students and wound up you know
kind of serendipitously finding divita
who provides a lot of dialysis care
and they're also on the the innovation
front of you know how do we address
things like
diabetes and just general chronic kidney
disease
from a big healthcare scale and not just
what a doctor or a nurse is doing every
single day with the patient
so i i joined the divida program
after my mba after spending a summer
with with ccg
and kind of getting additional
healthcare contacts there
and yeah it's been a whirlwind i
graduated from business school in a
little bit of about a year ago so
may 2020 and it's been a fascinating
time to be
in a dialysis clinic during covid um
when when we were short after when
things were going crazy i was the person
who was
you know running out to the parking lot
and giving patients coveted tests
so i've got a lot of good exposure there
and it's been really
heartwarming to see that you know the
path from from you know a rural
um public school to to yale through
stars
um you know through through a business
school program
has led me to be able to have a strong
impact um
where you know if i have a navajo
patient who can't figure out how to
apply for medicare
i can help with that and it's very
rewarding to be able to do that
so i i want to encourage you know the
whole class
here and and you know more recent alumni
that
your your path might be winding i know
we come into yale thinking like
i'm going to be a doctor i'm going to be
a psychologist i'm going to be an
engineer
you know the world throws different
things your way so
be okay with that it's not the end of
the world if plan a doesn't go exactly
how it was supposed to um certainly for
me i had no idea that i would
wind up in in kidney care working
directly with native american
populations which is
you know very much the dream but but
wasn't expected
i would also like to encourage you guys
to just take up space
um i think during my time at yale
i very much just like put my head down i
think kind of on a stereotypical front
minorities are
are trained to you know be quiet just
like get through it do well
but but not raise ruckus i think
so much of my success was
linked to having close relationships
with you know the professors and the phd
students and different mentors who
were really invested in our success and
of course said like you're welcome to
pop by any time
but what that means is you will be so
much better off and have a much easier
go of this
if you you know take up that office hour
space if you go have one-on-ones
and build this relationship so um you
know
all of us here speaking on the panel
today are
very invested in current student success
so please reach out to any of us
i'm very open to that very excited to
pave a way for you guys to do
even even better than we've done so
thanks for having me here today
thank you very much caressa for those
sagely advice
our next speaker is courtney williams
senior staff scientist
oncology and angiogenesis department at
regeneron pharmaceuticals
courtney thanks so much dean chang
i'm hoping you all can see my slides
um my name is courtney williams i am
class of 01
this is my 20th reunion year
and i am glad carissa went right before
me because
i think it is important to remember that
your path can be a winding one even
though mine was not
so i did go kind of straight shot from
undergrad
to grad school to a postdoc to a job
and some of that was kind of financial
not wanting to
have my loans come out of deferment and
things like that but
i think as the first two speakers were
examples that
the paths can differ and you can still
get to where you want to go
um so i've got some old pictures here
for everybody
so um i was um
at yale from i'm sorry i'm just gonna
have a pointer so i could point people
out from
1997 to 2001 i majored in
mbnb and i was able to participate in
stars one star summer and stars
ii all of that thanks to dr iona black
who you heard mentioned earlier and
who's right here who saw me in her
chemistry class and
just for whatever reason decided to that
she
like i was going to be in her program
and she was going to make sure
that that happened and it allowed me to
get into a lab i worked with dr
joanne sweezey who was part of the
like the larger graduate school faculty
but her lab was in the department of
therapeutic radiology
at the yale school of medicine she's
since moved
recent her lab recently to arizona but
there i worked on polymerase beta
interacting proteins
during dna mismatch repair in mammalian
meiosis
and just to give you an idea these are
some of my
friends from stars now a doctor now a
physician's assistant
now doing research um jessica lynn is in
your
program that's she and i were there at
the same time
um some of you might remember dean
george
so lots of um lots of folks
went on to successful careers in science
and law and lots of other things
but when i finished up at yale i
considered staying there for grad school
but
felt like i kind of needed to leave the
nest and
so i went to princeton where i was
in the department of molecular biology
and it was a relatively small
program at the time it's since grown
tremendously since i've been there
i was in the lab of dr jean
schwartzbauer
and i've just put some of my
publications here just so
um students can get an idea of the kind
of work that i did in these various labs
but my project was looking at breast
cancer and the role of the extracellular
matrix protein fibernectin
and breast cancer initiation and
progression
and i did use the 3d culture system
that was pretty cumbersome and not
not the best way to to look at these
problems and ask these kinds of
questions about the role of matrix and
stiffness
in in breast cancer progression and at
um a conference that i went to a senior
um scientist suggested to think of your
career
um like a toolbox and what are the
questions you want to ask and what tools
do you need in that toolbox
and then pick your your next steps based
on how to get those tools
and so i took that advice to heart and i
realized that
i knew a lot about the biology but it
didn't know a lot about the engineering
that it would take
to design systems that i really needed
to ask the kind of questions that i
wanted to ask
so from there i went to mit
for my postdoc in the lab of dr linda
griffith
in the department of biological
engineering and some people do know her
she's a macarthur genius grant winner
but
if you've ever seen the picture of the
nude mouse with a human ear growing on
its back
that was her uh postdoctoral research
that produced that
um and so in her lab there at mit i
basically was able to
uh up my engineering game and work on
designing culture systems to help
maintain the function of primary
hepatocytes
which is important for drug testing
because if these
cells don't maintain their
differentiation then you can't look at
toxicity because you don't know
if drugs are being properly metabolized
but so i
worked with a team of of material
scientists and other
engineers to come up with two different
systems for culturing these primary
hepatocytes
to get them to maintain that function
and
um when i went looking for a job
i had previously seen information about
regeneron pharmaceuticals and it was
near where i grew up i grew up in the
hudson valley in new york state
and um it turns out my cousin's
wife's best friend from high school
worked at regeneron and i found that out
through linkedin
and that connection um i had i talked
with her
my cousin put me in touch and she sent
my cv
on to the hr department at regeneron
and it turned out that they were looking
for someone to design
in vitro cell culture systems to
complement their in vivo
tumor work and basically i was kind of
the perfect candidate for that because
i came from a background of instead of
you know one
culture system is the solution for all
all engineering needs i approached it
from a much more like what signals do
you need
this is how we can um we can ask those
questions
and so i've been there for 10 years and
i started as a scientist
and i've studied a bunch of different
things as well as doing a lot of stem
outreach these are some of my
publications here
and i can talk more about that in the
breakout group because i don't want to
go over time
and i definitely want time for this
slide so this is the t-shirt that i
still have with our logo
from the summer star summer in 1999.
um that is me and that is my friend
lauren
who's now a doctor um and some more
pictures
of we've got you know a marine biologist
we've got some lawyers there's dr black
researcher
uh wealth capital i looked up some folks
last night
wealth capital person um doctor memorial
sloan kettering
um so a lot of people went on to do a
lot of successful stuff we've got like
people in education um plenty of doctors
i still run into stars people
working in the various areas of the life
sciences
but it's definitely been it was
in stars was instrumental into helping
me
stay in science and be successful in
science and i
really owe that all to dr black who um
was leading stars when i was an
undergraduate and kind of
saw something in me and decided to
really
despite my resistance to joining stars
really
decided to make sure i got in the
program and she really was a champion
for me as an undergraduate and the
program
that uh stars was with dr nelson was
really instrumental into my success as
an undergrad
and leaving me very well prepared uh for
graduate school
so with that i am finished a little over
time but i look forward
to talking to students in the breakout
um
in the breakout groups so thanks so much
thank you very much courtney our next
speaker is thomas howard
a current medical student at the harvard
mit md phd program
thomas
thank you sandy i hope everyone can see
my slides here
i wanted to speak briefly today about
some of my experiences as a first
generation college student
and in particular how in medical school
it really felt like all of my classmates
had physicians for parents
and now this wasn't quite true of course
but there definitely seemed to be this
wealth of knowledge that many of my
classmates had
that wasn't taught in our classrooms and
weren't in any of our books
and of one of the many examples of this
on my very first rotation
coming back from my phd years
was surgery and the intern handed me a
copy of the patient list that might have
looked something like this
and it's mostly a list of tasks that
need to get done and as the medical
student you're trying to be helpful
you're trying to get some of these done
for the residents and as you can see
so much of medicine is all of this
shorthand and acronyms to try to figure
out what's going on with each of these
patients
and fortunately i knew many of this
but there was one acronym that was
popping up all over the place
ntd and i had no idea what that meant
i was racking my brain to try to figure
out what test
or antibiotic or whatever this might
mean
and when i failed at that i did what
every good medical student does which is
consult dr google
but every place that i looked the only
thing i saw for ntd was a neural tube
defect which is something that can
happen in the developing
fetus and certainly was not the medical
abbreviation that i was looking
for so i sheepishly
asked the intern i said i'm so sorry if
i should know this
but could you please tell me what ntd
means and then that's when she said it
just means nothing
to do it wasn't a medical abbreviation
at
all it was just a shorthand on that list
of tasks
now when i think back at what has been
13 years of higher education i
really appreciate the fact that i had a
chance as part of the star summer
program
to learn many of these things and so
that's
both the programming that recognizes
that not all of us come in with the same
background and the same information
but then more importantly connecting us
with mentors who can try to help us
navigate those waters
at that point i had no idea what
graduate school was
or what one might do with a phd
or what being a pi might be like and i'm
so thankful for steve and maria who
welcomed me into their lab
and taught me all of these things and
then put me on the road to applying for
md phd programs
after yale i was also very fortunate to
have great phd mentors at harvard
and particularly people who could model
what it was like to care for patients
as well as to run a lap
and now i think many of you guys have
already experiencing that
as soon as you learn information you can
start passing that on to others as well
and so one of the things that i'm most
proud of of my time
in those labs is that i recruited and
was able to mentor an undergrad melinda
and a research technician taylor who
were both
phenomenal and so helpful for our work
and we had
all of these people contribute many of
them who were postdocs or
professors themselves and it was melinda
and taylor who we were able to give the
most credit
for uh as part of this team effort
and what i'm most proud of is we were
also able to help them
even in just little ways to get them
into medical school themselves and
they're going to move on with their
dreams to become
doctors as well and lastly i just wanted
to mention that the greatest gift i got
from yale was meeting my
now wife tara we got annexed from our
colleges
junior year to arnold hall i'm not sure
if that's something that still happens
but if that's an experience you're
having
there might be some unexpected positives
that come from it
so thank you all for listening i'm so
excited that i'll be able to talk with
some of you later on
and i'm very happy to reach out by email
or anything that i can be helpful with
in the future
thank you very much thomas our next
speaker
is aydah bermard who is a current
graduate student at nsf fellow
aydah yeah sure uh
so right my name is ida bermard i
graduated from yale in 2015 with a bs in
physics
and i was a stars 2 student and i'm
currently a grad student in planetary
science at caltech
so my current research is focused on
exoplanets which is basically exactly
what they sound like they're
planets that exist outside the solar
system orbiting stars other than the sun
so these days i'm working on projects to
try and tease out possible correlations
between the chemical compositions of the
stars that host
these exoplanets and the types of the
planets themselves
so one example of this could be does a
star rich in
rocky elements like iron or magnesium
tend to host planetary systems of a
certain type
like say maybe close in gas giants or
rather
smaller multi-planet systems and
figuring out these sorts of correlations
can tell us more about the
chemical histories of planets outside
our solar system which i find super
fascinating because
i think of other planets as not just
things but other places
places that we can learn more about and
maybe travel to one day
and maybe amenable toasting life so i'm
super grateful for the start i got in
science research at yale a large
part of which was participation in the
stars program which
allowed me to conduct research in the
astro department and also gave me access
to a community of scientists
who are working on really cool research
that was very different from my own
which is always nice to hear about
and the mentorship i received as a star
student was also super helpful for me
i was able to build close relationships
with post-docs and other senior
scientists at yale who
also were women of color and who were
honest with me about challenges that i
may face in grad school
and encouraged me that i would be able
to do it anyway
so these days when i'm not working on
science i spend a lot of time on
diversity equity and inclusion
initiatives at caltech
i currently serve as the diversity chair
on the grad student council
and we do everything that we can to
support an advocate for caltech grads
with marginalized identities
i'm also really passionate about science
education outreach and i've been going
into pasadena elementary schools as part
of a grad student team
to teach biweekly science classes for
the better part of the last four years
i honestly didn't think i would spend so
much time on outreach and dei
initiatives when i got to caltech but it
turns out that
caltech while an exceptional institute
for science and research
is not the most diverse place which i
think on some level can be said about
any scientific community
especially once you climb past the
undergrad level so when i came and saw
how it was i really wanted to do
everything to uh to help that wasn't my
power
so if you're interested in talking to me
about any of that or my science or
anything at all i'd be super happy to do
so later
thank you very much ida our next speaker
is ben
bartolomi who's a current data scientist
at navy federal credit union
hey uh good morning everyone uh
yeah my name is member ptolemy class of
2016.
i majored in chemical engineering and
i'm now
a data scientist at a pretty big credit
union
uh before i start i want to give a shout
out to
my uh my girl mary who's the current
stars one student
super awesome really incredible person
and all the
and i really look forward to chatting
with the
uh with as many of you as possible in
the coming years
um in terms of how like stars has
impacted me in my
journey i want to give a few pretty
material examples but
on perhaps like on the softer skill side
um
the ability to clearly communicate as uh
perhaps better evidence than uh courtney
and thomas's slides is really really
important
and you'll see some abysmal
truly abhorrent things as you go about
your life and so i'm going to give you
an example
uh i just had this slide shown to me
uh earlier this week at work
about there are about 200 slides this
one stood out the most
and these were created by accenture
consultants
who get paid six figures and you don't
have to know what any of this means i
don't know what any of this means but
someone sat down
they built this slide and they thought
yeah this is really the clearest way to
communicate this information
this is abysmal who knows what's going
on here and then ironically they have
here in the middle
some circle thing that says elicit and
clarify this is a joke
and so you know the this would not be
a professor moreno approved i'm sure
but in terms of clear communication this
is the way to not do it stars will help
you
get on the right track and start your
well outside your way off um
well in terms of other things
uh and thankfully there's a breakout
room on this later which is awesome
um but it stars also taught me how to be
a
really good mentee and also an improving
mentor
which is to say that like as a mentee
and also as a mentor but like
um you know you
throughout your journey with stars you
get the opportunity to learn how to
listen well
to give conversations like the space to
breathe how to enter conversations with
like a
humility and an open mind um asking
thoughtful questions
of the people that you're in dialogue
with um and then
you know on either side of the
interaction the ability to
like for consistent follow-up and you
know there's a type of thing where you
know
your mentor or advisor or whoever
um that you might be reaching out to you
know reaching out it doesn't have to be
like a kind of continuous thing it can
be
um but even something as perhaps
infrequent in quotes
as a six months to a year that type of
thing
but it's super valuable um and
uh it also emphasizes you know in terms
of this like mentor mentee relationship
but there's like so many people so many
alums
that want to help uh you know
and i think right now in total at um
in terms of yale alums there's like 175
000
plus the overwhelming majority of them
do not get reached out to
and they would love to help uh
and um and but like this is a way in
which you can differentiate yourself
because there's a
massive massive amount of wisdom that's
available out there right
and if you just reach out there's a
really high likelihood that they'll say
oh yeah i'd put the chat with you and
you can have access to that
um a really great example of that on my
end is that
excuse me um i've been looking to start
a company soon with some friends
and i needed some i needed some insight
from kind of on the legal side in the
financial sector
and so i reached out to this one alumni
who was
the uh formerly a commissioner of the
security and exchange commission under
obama
and i was like hey can i get your
insight on this and she
gave all kinds of really valuable
insight and it was just by my reaching
out and she was happy to help and
and now she kind of continues to be an
advisor to me in many ways
um but you know all i had to do was ask
and and so yeah this
concept of being you know a good mentee
and similarly on the men per cycle
you can develop your software skills
that are extraordinarily valuable
um and so yeah and then the last thing i
want to chat about and this is on a more
personal level
similar to thomas um is that
i i want to
talk about my what else
something else that stars provided was
an avenue to meet my
current wife i met my wife brooke um
over star summer uh you can actually see
that even though i graduated pretty
recently
we were um we were this camera quality
was actually the best
technology that was available those few
years ago which is kind of
incredible uh you know science really
does progress
very quickly and stars contributes to
that so thank you
uh we were on the bus to the beach here
you can see
that we are on a boat you can tell by
our posturing that we were extremely
popular
even though we're standing by ourselves
and you may be thinking
man how did this guy come to sit before
you and he's presenting this panel
well a few years later you can have a
glow up
just like this boom we made it baby and
so yeah brook and i got married
a few months ago um august 2020
i don't know we were the as mary put it
the first
stars cross lovers to get married
hopefully we're not the last
but you know have fun with it it's a
good time stars will
um you know in many ways help set you up
on the
f and a very fruitful one
thank you guys for listening thank you
so much ben that was terrific um our
next speaker is clarence agby
a senior data scientist at brex clarence
hello thanks for the introduction um my
name is clarence agb
class of 2009 uh which is a while ago at
this point
majored in electrical engineering i was
part of calhoun now grace
hopper college and if you all remember
nothing from this conversation or this
talk
um i absolutely want you to remember
this one thing
that you know basically carissa stole it
already
um is make your own lane make your own
path
um and don't be afraid to pivot right
and so one of the things that i'll you
know kind of talk about
is my own path my own journey through
stem
um and how stars played a role in that
for me
i i'm originally from new york so shout
out to any new yorkers on the call
son of immigrants you know shout out to
all of you as well
um came to yale and i wasn't really sure
what my path was gonna be
i mean i i was into like ap math ap
science and all of that but you know i
came to yelp
just to give myself the option of like
what if i wanted to be an english major
or an econ or a spanish major because
these were all things i was interested
in
and i would say definitely econ 115 is
that the introductory course it
definitely crushed all of my hopes of
that
i think i got a c in that class um
quickly learned english was not for me
spanish also not great for me
even though that summer after freshman
year i
worked at a temp agency as part of
bulldogs in the rockies
um translating uh basically from english
and spanish
job requirements and things like that so
you must be wondering like well
why what does this have to do with
engineering
um all of this is kind of like on the
journey of things that
failed for me right and ultimately
i figured out sometime around sophomore
year that
i was really really into engineering and
um
i think freshman year i took physics but
it wasn't until i took some of the
hardcore engineering classes
uh that i was like oh yeah this is
really clicking for me this is really
making sense
um and you know in that time
uh during sophomore year i think one
class that really stood out for me was
professor kutz's class ee350 i don't
even know if they still have that class
professor cruz essentially
uh ran the digital uh i think it's the
acoustics lab he was really into like
bats and acoustics but
essentially it was all about robotics
and and um
what how do you uh use systems to do
very intelligent things
um and in that class he had us build
like a differential drive robot
um which i had never done before i
thought
wow this is really cool and that really
piqued my interest
and got me thinking about grad school um
the summer after sophomore year i ended
up
going to a program similar to stars it
was nsf funded but it was at georgia
tech
with predominantly you know minority
black and brown people
women and it really
made room for me to one do research uh
at an institution
and two um uh
just figure out how to get into grad
school because it was such an ambiguous
process
um and and it just felt like a big
barrier and a big hump
so uh did that and i would say that
program specifically much like stars one
at yale
um really made me want to be a phd
student i mean i came back from my
summer in atlanta and i was like
research where can i do more of it and
that's where at that point dean george
kind of intersected and was like have
you heard of stars too
um and by the way i should say a lot of
the stars one folks are very tight-knit
like it
i i kind of have a little bit of fomo
about not doing that program but
you know i didn't want to be in new
haven not one moment longer during the
summer so
so i left but um when i came back like i
said junior year i
put my head down and i talked to
professor cootes and i was like let's do
some research together
and so i applied to stars2 was a stars2
student and did research for about a
year and a half
which eventually turned into my senior
project
in that year and a half i learned a lot
about ambiguity i learned a lot about
scoping projects um i trekked
i lived at bechton lab and i trekked
often to the fm house
where i did you know i was i was normal
person right
so i didn't just do research 24 7. i was
part of like
you know gospel choir i was part of
stepping out you know i saw people
um i had to maintain a social life and
be a real person
but on top of that um you know i was
also really motivated to do research and
to get into grad school and and do all
these wonderful things
and i was really gung-ho about sticking
on this path of like
research right so you know eventually
things worked out i ended up um like i
said i it became my senior project you
can actually
google it i think the youtube link is
out there you can ask me about it later
um and i got into
you know something that people won't
often tell you is that
some of these programs are a little bit
of a crap shoot so i got into two of the
eight
graduate programs that i applied to um
and i was lucky enough to get into
uh carnegie mellon for my ms phd program
so
you know don't feel bad if you don't get
into all of the things that you
want to do um my motto is to kind of
feel forward and feel often right
and like i said earlier you know don't
be afraid to pivot so i went to
uh cmu um did hardcore engineering there
uh actually did research in smart
buildings uh
as part of like uh i was also an nsf
graduate
research fellow um so i i was doing
research and how do we make buildings
smarter
and um build really fancy control
systems to do that i was writing proofs
for days
and ultimately after five years of doing
that you know
i i was pooped out i couldn't go any
further so you know hats off to you dr
williams
and to all the other doctors that stayed
on you know and did research and became
professors
i took a completely different route um
and was like i'm going into industry
um i became a software engineer at a
defense company
uh and then eventually pivoted into this
very brand new thing called data science
and at the time it was brand new now
everybody is kind of like oh yeah data
science that's a thing
um but i say all of this to say that in
you know the process of me you know
getting to where i am now
where i feel like i'm in a job that
completely suits
all of my abilities um some of these
things didn't exist at that time
and uh i think it's okay that
it doesn't exist now you know you might
be built to do something
that is completely brand new you might
not be built for
you know the traditional path um or you
might not be built for the
non-traditional path
either there is a lot of ambiguity and
stress and imposter syndrome and all of
that there as well so
um you know definitely feel free to go
to all the
breakout rooms but definitely come to
mind um if you want to talk a little bit
more i can speak to
just about anything in that experience
right from you know
yale to grad school to what it's like
now working in the engineering world
um in tech and and where to go from
there
certainly my career is still taking
pivots
and i'm still making a path for myself
so i don't claim to have it all figured
out and i don't think any of the other
speakers do
but certainly we can help you where you
are now
and you know work together on the on the
journey so
thanks thanks for that thank you very
much clarence
our next speaker is rahul navero
assistant professor of chemistry at
occidental college
bro hi everybody uh
my name is raul navarro i'm currently
an assistant professor at occidental
college in southern california
um first off i just wanted to say i'm
really excited to see
like so many familiar faces um
clarence tina some of my classmates uh
dean chun who i knew as master chun of
berkeley college back then
professor zim who i didn't have the
pleasure of taking a class with but i
remember your face very well spending a
lot of time
in sterling um so
let's see uh i guess i'll tell you a
little bit about how
i got involved with stars and how it led
to where i am today
mean i you know the sort of it is that
um
it essentially molded my the person i am
today in a lot of ways
um you know i started at yale
coming from i was born and raised in l.a
you know
son of of immigrant parents who had just
come
come from mexico right and you know they
kind of just came over here to give us
all these opportunities
and so i took that very seriously as a
kid and i was lucky enough to get into
yale
thinking i was going to do pre-med
everyone's kind of touched on this idea
of these meandering paths right and so
that was mine i was definitely pre-med
when i first started i had a general
vague sense of you know i wanted to help
people but i'm really not i don't think
i really understood how then at the time
um and then i tried the stars program my
freshman year i remember
i remember the end of my freshman year
it was you know i saw a flyer for it
i was like well you know med schools
look for research experience
let's give it a shot and honestly the
rest is history i had my first summer
research experience dr black was the
person
who really helped me out there
um you know i'm really embedded to her
and get it to her because
i still remember the fact that it was
like a few weeks before the summer
started and i still hadn't picked out a
lab which apparently i was supposed to
do
and so dr black of course comes in and
you know
essentially holds my hand through the
entire process
which which which i really needed at the
time um because i had no clue what i was
doing
i'm helping me figure out a lab a
chemistry lab i still remember the first
day
of my time there because it was such a
crazy experience for me i had never seen
anything like it
right grad school to me was such a
foreign thing
um and i was there in that first day
thinking like wow i was in a lab and
just
an amazement that i could do something
like that and get paid for it
that to me was just such a crazy concept
um and so you know the rest is history i
took i i enjoyed my time there it was
tough
you know learning a lot of the stuff you
do as a researcher
when you had just taken general
chemistry
but i got a lot of great training in
that first summer
i then took organic chemistry my second
year class that i think a lot of people
dread
taking and i certainly wasn't a big fan
my first semester but
um i once i think i devoted more time to
it
and you know went to office hours and
got a lot of help for it i
i became i became really good at it and
um
really wanted to do research in it and
so then i pushed my professor at the
time
let me do research was no longer at yale
but um
he uh he graciously let me be in his lab
and that's when i really i think found
the great intersection of for me um
the kind of research that i wanted to do
where i kind of overlapped with a lot of
my interests so for me it was kind of
about building molecules
um and that i thought was really cool um
so i did that for the rest of my time at
yale
it was more or less two years that i was
in uh professor glenn michelio's lab
um and you know the decision to apply to
grad school for me wasn't necessarily a
conscious one like i
i reached the point my junior year where
it was i was thinking about grad schools
without having sort of thought about the
fact that i was no longer like a pre-med
student and was actively thinking about
like
i'm going to be in graduate school next
and so for me it was kind of a decision
was kind of made for me
in that way
and so let's see i
so after yale you know i also applied to
grad school clarence mentioned you know
it's really grad school really is kind
of a crap shoot you'll get into places
and you're gonna think like
i got him here but i didn't get in here
it's like doesn't make any sense
um but that's just how it goes right so
i was uh
excited to uh get into caltech
um and so i i went back to and i was
also kind of missing
you know being california having spent i
love yale but i
didn't love the weather this is the
summary of my four years at um
um so i came back to do my phd at
caltech where i did it in chemistry
um and you know my experience there i'm
happy to talk about it
in in the breakout sessions i had a
great time there i
you know i got a chance to really dive
into a more organic chemistry research
thinking about making
these you know what we refer to as these
you know natural products molecules you
can isolate from nature that have some
interesting biological properties
potential to treat some human disease
um where i really got a chance to
explore that and also really develop my
sense of the senses of identity that i
started to develop at yale
to be honest and so um you know i think
aida mentioned uh you know doing
starting to do things outside of the
research realm of health and i think for
me that was also equally true
i got a chance to really um
uh started to develop a sense of i guess
balance
between research and celebrating who i
am and pursuing those interests and so i
i became really involved with
reviving and really establishing the
lgbt group
on on campus at caltech which was really
a rewarding experience
um and so you know coming out of grad
school keep in mind the time here
um i would did a i did a postdoc uh
and so i went up to stanford university
to do some research in chemical biology
trying to
trying something a little bit different
um applying some of the compounds that i
you know develop or
made in grad school and thinking
thinking about thinking more broadly
about how to
how they can be used to study uh some
sort of biological function
so i went up there and spent three or
four years
almost four years as a postdoc
also happy to unpack that experience you
know at every each of these transitions
i think we all you know you get thrown
for a loop in what you're doing and
and in each one of these i think um was
super challenging for me in
a lot of ways and and really what it
came down to for me was just
starting to develop a sense of community
right i think i mentioned i
forget who else mentioned right as you
go up as you climb beyond
right uh undergrad your community starts
to get
noticeably smaller like almost
exponentially smaller as you climb each
rank
and so it becomes a lot more important
to make sure you establish those
connections to make sure
um you recognize that you're not doing
this alone that you're not kind of
swimming in your head by yourself which
i often find myself doing
right um navigating impostor syndrome
it's one of those things that
um is very challenging and never really
leaves you and so it's good to develop
good techniques
um including reaching out to people and
so now i get a chance to
you know do a little bit of research
that i'm at a liberal arts institution
and so we're really
teaching focused on teaching i get to do
a lot of teaching
and really think about really creative
ways to deliver classes like organic
chemistry
i have a group a group of undergraduate
researchers
um and so that's been really rewarding
something i got to do at yale was
stars one stars twos i did all the stars
things basically since the end of my
freshman year
i got a chance to you know be a
facilitator and tutor people and that's
something that i
i think really inspired me to keep doing
that
sort of kind of work today um and then i
guess one last thing
in terms of advice i think to give to
the younger students is
um i would say to make sure you let
yourself
take opportunities right so it's one
thing to take an opportunity and people
tell you that
but it's a whole another to be in a
mindset where you can say
like i i can do that
and i think i struggled a lot with that
as an undergrad
always kind of second guessing myself
and not being sure
that's not really for me right kind of
shutting it down before i even consider
it
um and so that's sort of one i think
mental barrier that i
i took a lot of time to overcome and so
there's i think
you have plenty of you have a lot of
opportunities while you're at yale and i
think it's just important to make sure
that you put yourself in a position
where you can
say yes i can try that and yes you know
i can do it as well
i'm happy to i'm looking forward to
chatting with all of you in the breakout
sessions a little bit
thank you thank you very much rahul
our next speaker is luo
a data scientist and ceo
excellent thank you so much sandy um by
the way
i've been i've been messaging uh dean
george and she says
she says to say hi she also says to uh
to give a hug to clarence
um yes once again my name is panoluo
um i am a um
i am a data scientist who works as
analytics lead
at music tech startup band camp
which helps support artists in musicians
in actually making money
for their music online uh in comparison
to
to spotify but we'll not get into that
um and i'm also
the ceo and chief curator of a music
community that i founded four years ago
called sound shop which is um
effectively
a a ted talk meets a concert
uh musicians uh talk about their music
and they perform their music and then
have an intellectual conversation
uh with the audience um so
in terms of um in terms of what i want
to talk to you guys about
um i would say that uh the important
thing that i want to impart on you
is is two things actually uh the first
is that you should
pursue your intellectual curiosity uh
wherever that leads
uh even if it leads you away from what
you perceived to be your path
um and the other thing would be that
even if you do
go far afield from what you expected
your path to be
that the time that you spent prior is
not wasted and that actually
you know you bring all of it with you
and you're actually able to
you know re reorient those skills in
powerful ways and new environments
um so i just wanted to uh to kind of
like
kick this off metaphorically with this
uh with this painting
that i painted this was uh i painted
this in
um high school uh my senior year of high
school
um so my mom's a painter and she's also
an art professor um and art historian
um and she also encouraged
me to go into the sciences like at the
exclusion of the arts
so there's this kind of like constant
dichotomy in me um
around the arts versus the sciences um
and um in conjunction with that
you know when i started when i started
at yale i was deciding between
um psychology between uh i knew that i
wanted to do neuroscience
but i was trying to decide between
whether i wanted to be on the on the
more bio side of things
or the psych side of things and so um
being able to
you know spend a summer in in a
neurobiology lab
up at kbt um was very influential in
sort of helping me realize that you know
i wanted to go more in the psych
side of things rather than uh the
biology side of things
um but you know as i continued down that
path i was thinking of becoming a doctor
and
in the end you know i decided that that
was not
what i wanted and i realized ultimately
it was what my mom
wanted me to do and there's really no
compromising between what you want to do
and what your parents want you to do and
i tried to convince myself
otherwise but you know right before i
graduated i
i called my mom was like hey i don't
want to become a doctor
she's like what are you going to do i'm
like i'm going to go into advertising
and my mom was like what
[Laughter]
but um you know i i decided to go that
direction because
i basically saw that i figured that you
know my background in in neuroscience
and psychology would be useful for
advertising
um to the degree that that's true as an
an entry-level position
in advertising not not really
necessarily the case
um but you know my my my interest in
um in in stem and especially the the
technology side of things
always saw me doing things that were
more technical in any role that i was
in um and also the the presentation
skills
uh that i gained through through stars
and cultivated
through um through my research research
background also proved hugely
instrumental
in in my journey and so um you know
as as time moved along i moved as and as
i moved up in the advertising world
i became more and more technical so
becoming a data analyst becoming
then a data engineer and ultimately um a
data scientist and all that i owe to
you know the the stem background uh that
i have
um and then along the way um you know
mentorship has always been important to
me
um you know both within stem uh but
sorry both within stars
and then you know uh throughout my time
as an undergrad and so
as i've sort of moved up in the world i
have been
you know i've been mentoring people i've
taken people who uh
who work in the advertising business and
they're more client-facing and they're
less technical
and i kind of mentor them into becoming
technical uh so i've been able to have
you know a huge impact on the people
around me and so
you know i kind of had this narrative in
my in myself as i was moving
up the ranks that like oh like all the
stuff that i did
before you know was not really useful
and why did i spend all that time doing
pre
doing pre-med stuff but i think me being
invited back to this
has actually made me reflect on how it's
actually persisted me with me which is
really cool
um and then i know and i know i'm over
time and i actually timed myself so i
wouldn't um but the final thing um is
you know my music community you know you
think like oh
you know you're doing this music
curation thing like how does how does
that relate to your to your past
background
um and for the longest time it didn't
really relate or at least i didn't see
it as relating
but i met this guy named kyle mengelkamp
who is a
stroke survivor he had a massive stroke
at age 11.
complete retrograde amnesia um had to
rehabilitate himself from scratch
and now he's 20 years on from that
stroke and he
he runs a brain community where he
brings together
um academics and you know uh and
survivors of traumatic brain injuries
and they're all
talking about the brain they're all like
you know mutually supporting each other
and so he he and i now do a lot of
collaborative events
around music and the brain and it's kind
of like you know it's kind of like the
book music ophelia
as like an event so like we'll bring
together like
you know clinical psychologists who like
run
an institution around music um
at berkeley school of music or will
bring to get bring in
like a psych academic who's doing
research on on music
or you know practitioners at the
intersection of music in the brain
and in one of those events i've actually
i actually gave a talk
where i basically articulated my theory
that music is the baseline skill
upon which language is built and i
supported that using evidence from
um linguistics uh neuroscience
uh uh what was it uh you know
evolutionary biology clinical psychology
and so like i i'm now in a place where
i'm like
able to like bring the stem the stem
background into
what what once seemed like a more sort
of like
uh you know fully arts oriented
uh sort of thing so back to bringing it
all full circle
you can have it all you can make you can
make the arts and the sciences
uh live together and so that's that's
what i just want to
want to convey to everyone thank you
thank you very much akano
luo now next speaker is tina liu
the research specialist at uc berkeley
tina
hi so first of all thanks for inviting
me and um
it's great to see all these alums doing
all these amazing things
uh at this point at all different sort
of stages of their career so thanks a
lot for this just this opportunity to
come and
join this event today um so i'm gonna be
talking a little bit about kind of my
journey um at yale actually and also a
bit after um mainly focusing on
one particular recent kind of work that
i'm doing on rna diagnostics
related to covid but also give sort of
just short vignettes of um
some of the past work that i've also
done before so as
sandy was saying i'm currently a
research specialist in the lab where i
actually just
um was a postdoc until very very
recently
i was class of 2008 in the stars ii
program
um in lynne regan's lab and and bnb
and um i think one sort of you know this
event really made me think about what
what sort is the common theme that
connects
my past work because i worked on a
couple several different areas
i really think that one thing that
drives my sort of interest in research
is really understanding life
at the molecular level so you know
obviously
a whole multicellular organism is
composed of cells and then if you
zoom in more has these complex
intracellular structures
called organelles and that when you
further break that down into
macromolecules
which include proteins sugars dna rna
lipids that all kind of enable life to
exist which is just kind of an amazing
thought to me
and so i worked in a couple different
areas one is engineering proteins which
are one type of macromolecule
i'm looking at membrane proteins so the
connection between proteins and lipids
so two different types of molecules and
the more recently
um harnessing a type of proteins called
crispr cast nucleuses
for rna detection so again looking at
two different interactions between two
different types of macromolecules and
harnessing them for different functions
outside of their
endogenous function and so at yale uh
what i was doing in the stars2 program
i was in lynne regan's lab so she's
since left yale she's now at university
of edinburgh
but she was a professor in the mbnb
department and
she gave me this project to try to
design new proteins
based on this tpr protein which is a
natural protein but we wanted to give it
new properties so that they could bind
to a novel target or any target that you
want
and one of the examples or the value of
doing that is that you can use those
design proteins here
to target any pathway in a cell so in
this case
the design protein that um i was
actually a part of
designing and engineering we could put
into yeast cells and we could actually
inhibit
the specific pathway that was the
protein that
inbound was uh part of and so that
actually led to
um my first you know
co-first author paper um from the stars
program was the work that i did in
winslow which is you know super exciting
as an undergrad it's not something that
i expected
at the time but it was amazing to just
have that continuous support from
stars to start a program start a
research project you know in my
second semester freshman year and
actually get it to the point where we
could actually present it and share it
with the scientific community so that
was really
really amazing experience starting
starting off
then after yale i went to harvard for
in the bbs program biological and
biomedical sciences
where i really wanted to still work on
molecular
interactions and events but understand
how they happened in the context of
cellular pathways
and so i joined tom rappaport's lab that
worked on
how organelles in the cell are shaped
and how the proteins
so this particular family protein called
the lasting proteins how they interact
with each other and also with the
membrane
to fuse memories together and that it
turns out to be a key
sort of event in the formation of
organelles which
as many of you might have um already
already know
are sort of the internal compartments or
rooms
of a cell if you think of a cell as a
building and you know the kitchen having
specialized function in the bedroom
living room and so on so the organelles
are kind of see have those
compartmentalized functions inside the
cell
and then after this um i went to
jennifer doudna's lab at uc berkeley
where and her lab works on crispr cast
systems
which are actually bacterial immune
systems
and these immune systems use these
proteins protein rna complexes called
rna guided nucleuses that protect them
against
invading viruses and one sort of key
step again
if we look down at the molecular level
is that these this
immune immune pathway uh requires the
use of these protein rna effectors to
really um
enact immunity essentially and so
as some of you might have heard before
many of these types of nucleuses can be
hardest for dna or rna editing in cells
so this is
uh you know a wide ranging of the
applications that
are already kind of in use so there's
genome editing there's imaging of dna
inside cells
activating or oppressing certain genes
as well as rna imaging editing and
knock down and it's one of the kind of
values value of crispr cast is that it's
it's not that it's the first time that
dna editing has been achieved
but it's a tool that's really easy for
people to use so it really democratizes
you know manipulation and biology
but the thing that um i ended up working
on obviously this past year um given
that the you know pandemic started last
last spring or
early last year a lot of labs on campus
really tried to think about what we
could do to help
and one sort of area of need was of
course testing
and so we a couple labs in in our
building actually got together and
really just brainstormed lots of ideas
to figure out how can we use crispr
for rna diagnostics this concept of
using a crispr protein to detect
certain rna sequences isn't and isn't
new
but the problem was that previous
approaches even though they worked
they still needed higher sensitivity and
also higher speed for them to be really
relevant and useful in clinical
applications
and so we came up with this idea to try
to more efficiently couple together two
different crystal proteins
in tandem for really fast rna sections
so essentially it takes a system
that we're kind of separate systems
before on their own but
combine them together to see if we can
get a faster response and this is one
example of kind of
the signal that comes out so basically
we're looking for something that
rises as you uh over time
and so we had to make a couple
modifications with this system to
actually get it working well so you can
see on the left
this is a perfect example actually of
you know many people earlier
speaking of saying you know sometimes
things don't work and you can see here
on the left we tested multiple sort of
concentrations of the molecule that we
want to detect and we don't get very
good signal
but we found that actually by really
looking at the
function of this one protein that we
could engineer its activator by putting
this kind of
pink modification here to make it work
better
and essentially by just introducing that
single change you can see the difference
in signal here
uh from you know almost close to
baseline to this really robust response
and that actually increased our
sensitivity by a hundred fold
and so it was just really exciting to
see this it's kind of you know these
moments in science where
a lot of times things don't work the
first time and second time and third
time but then when they do work that one
time it's just a really incredible
feeling
and so we were able ultimately to sort
of in addition incorporate other
improvements to get to a sensitivity
that was sort of clinically useful which
is
at a molar concentration rate that's
about 30 or 30 copies per microliter of
sars kobe 2 rna in about 20 minutes
and in addition we since we have an
on-campus or testing lab
we're able to actually take some samples
that were left over
from their lab and see if we could use
our assay
to detect sarcoby to rna that were
actually from patient samples
and what you can see here so i won't go
to too much detail but this black line
is essentially we're looking for a
difference between this black line of
the pink line
and you can see here that you can see
this above the pink line which means
that it's positive
and again for here this is actually with
a lower viral load
so this number means that there's less
spiral particles there or rna there
and it's still above but it's closer to
the baseline
on the other hand though negative
samples all show that it was below this
pink uh baseline here so essentially we
could distinguish between positive and
negative samples
uh at this range of ct values between 8
and 29 which
correspond to some of the early
infectious stages of coping 19 and
that's really
nice for us because essentially when you
want to control a pandemic
it's not necessarily you have to have
the absolute most
sensitive tests you know in the world
actually what's more
important in some cases is be able to
frequently test and catch people at the
most infectious stages when they're most
likely to spread it to other people
and so it's really nice for us to see
that in this range between
less than 29 where most um positives in
this kind of group were
we could actually able we were able to
detect them with this uh
technology that we had developed
and so just to kind of conclude um
basically we found that these
unrelated crispr nucleuses were from
different sort of
bacteria different biological
systems could be really combined
together for fast and sensitive rna
detection
and that makes it that simplicity also
being this kind of a single
uh reaction makes it really amenable for
rapid testing
which is often for this point of care
diagnosis diagnosis
um compared to for example traditional
approaches which
require you know centralized lab a lot
of equipment trained personnel
and i think just to end with i think
again this sort of
goes toward the point that if you have
an understanding of how the molecules
work to drive a process in life
that can really lead to innovations that
are valuable
in biology research and medicine that's
not just true for this but also you can
see in
my mentor jennifer doudna's work on
crispr that you know crispr is a natural
bacterial system nobody ever thought
you know it was not designed for genome
editing but nowadays
uh it's been widely adopted for for
genome manipulation
um and so i think i have to end by
really thanking the mbmb program for
really
instilling that appreciation for
molecular events and also stars to
for their support and
of course mentors lynn regan jennifer
doudna and tom rappaport
and also the great endowment lab for for
their help and happy to talk more at the
breakout sessions
thank you very much tina our last alumni
speaker
today is elias curano he's a current md
phd student at yale medical school
and my stars one graduate coordinator
elias
hi everyone uh thanks for having me
today
my name is elias i'm a as dean chang
mentioned currently an md phd student at
yale but uh
graduated from yale a long time ago in
2012
um and you know i've been really
fortunate to be part of the stars
program
you know i remember my first day at yale
just feeling completely out of place you
know so i'm i'm
from a small town in florida hialeah
florida it's a really small city
in miami and growing up just like you
know in a spanish-speaking community
with spanish-speaking parents
you know i i never felt out of place i
always felt like i was home
and when i got to yale that feeling of
belonging was immediately
uh swept away from me and i immediately
fell out of place
and i think many of you here probably
share
with some of that feeling um and i
remember
you know even the smallest things it
made me feel like a foreigner
uh so one big thing in florida is
wearing these uh
these silk shirts these guys and uh i
remember wearing one probably my first
week
at yale and you know one of my floor
mates made you know some sort of uh
joke about about my shirt and i just
remember
immediately feeling like it didn't
belong here and i think
uh you know early grades you know my
first c at yale
uh uh compounded that feeling of not
belonging at yale feeling like
like i didn't belong and really you know
that first year i felt really lost and i
think
serving currently as the graduate
student coordinator for stars one
many students feel this way and and it
really doesn't matter what your
background is or where you're from and
it's really hard to feel like you belong
here especially if you know you're from
a
underrepresented community or a first
generation college student
it's really easy to feel lost and feel
like you don't have a community here at
yale
um but i remember my sophomore year i uh
interacted with dean garcia at la casa
and uh she really pointed me to the
stars program and
really pointed me to people who made me
feel like like i did belong at yale
and she was one of the first people who
really introduced me to the program and
introduced me to the faculty members
that were part of stars that had sort of
voluntarily chosen to mentor students
like myself which
was really remarkable uh to me at the
time uh
and i think like many of you have
mentioned you know dr black was just
uh an absolute force i mean
you could sort of be failing and and
messing up and not be on time for
something and she was after you she was
pushing you she was asking why you
weren't showing up to
review sessions you know i remember one
time i at the time when i was a student
she was hosting these nightly review
sessions for chemistry and
i think i missed it once and she's like
why aren't you here you're the student
who belongs here the most you need the
most help
and you know it was that level of
intensity and that level of like
sort of looking out for students and
chasing students down that i think is
really really remarkable and really
made a dr black stand out among all of
the faculty members here you know she
really uh
chased after you um and the same was
true for dr moreno so
you know i ended up doing star summer
and dr moreno
had a similar energy and a similar force
but you know she really taught me
how to succeed in science and how to
succeed uh in stem and
and that to me was a really uh really
remarkable just having someone who was
so accomplished in her own field in her
own right
take the time to mentor me and shepherd
me and
just teach me what i needed to know uh
from you know how to write an email that
was appropriate to a professor
uh to how to design a slide that didn't
look like the example we saw a little
bit earlier and i know
we all make jokes about that but it's
true i mean
you know the number one thing you're
doing as a graduate student or someone
in stem or
in any field is communicating and being
able to communicate effectively and
clearly is
just so invaluable um and it's a bit of
a softer skill but one that i really
credit uh stars with
you know you know i think stars for me
was was really the first time that
you know not only was i taught how to
succeed but i was also taught to
never give up you know i i think deep
down inside you know i always knew i
wanted to pursue stem
i you know i didn't have parents that
that um you know were scientists or went
to college for that matter
but you know the stars faculty members
really taught me uh to kind of pursue
that and and
never give up on that and really seek
mentors uh that could help me
along the way and um you know that was
extremely
invaluable for me so since that time as
a stars
uh student i you know i ended up doing
star summer as well as stars too
um one thing i'll mention that someone
actually said a little earlier today
is that in addition to the mentorship
one
key piece of the stars program was the
financial support that i received so
at the time when i was doing stars 1 and
stars 2
i had the opportunity to go to multiple
conferences and present multiple
posters and talks and it was because the
stars program paid for my lodging and
paid for my registration i mean
there was absolutely no way i was going
to be able to take advantage of those
opportunities
if stars wasn't financing those
opportunities for me and that was really
really invaluable
even with star skew you know the
opportunity to get paid to do research
to both further your
intellectual development and your
research skills while also
generating the income that perhaps you
need because you're sending money home
or you're paying for your own books or
you know paying for your own
day-to-day expenses it's really
something that you know i i sort of look
back and i think many of us feel the
same way
you know i really credit stars with sort
of saving me
uh in many ways and putting me on the
right track um
but since that time i i went on to start
an md phd program at yale thankfully
to most of my stars mentors including
dean chang um and you know have recently
started my own biotech uh and just
closed our series a
so you know i say that not to really
brag but just to say that you know i
went from getting
c's and chemistry and you know virtually
failing
out of out of the university uh to now
achieving some level of success and
it really wasn't something i did on my
own it was really something i did
because of stars and through the support
i received from star so
you know i'm just really grateful uh to
the students i've been able to mentor
through stars but
especially to the individuals who have
mentored me i mean it's really been an
invaluable
process and experience for myself and
you know i'm just really grateful uh to
be here with you all and
to see that uh so many people benefited
from this program and
uh decided to give back by being here
today so thank you all and uh thank you
dean chang for organizing all of this
and
putting us all together thank you very
much elias and thank you to all the
speakers in the morning session